the unwinnable Trump trade war is
starting to claim some victims
harley-davidson arguably one of the most
stereotypically American companies by
completely arbitrary jingoistic
standards is shifting production out of
the US for some of its motorcycles
because of the tariffs that have been
placed on American goods by the European
Union in direct retaliation to Donald
Trump's tariffs and this is the ripple
effect the most high-profile company so
far to say we're going to shift some
production away from the United States
and this is why you can't win
Trump puts tariffs on the EU which might
lead to X number of extra dollars being
spent on American goods because the
foreign goods are made more expensive
but then Harley moves some production
out of the US which causes a loss of Y
dollars in American earnings when
American earnings go down you lose tax
revenue people who would have earned
that money no longer have that money to
go and spend at local businesses and the
numbers just no longer work for Harley
Davidson it's super simple the math is
simple the tariffs from the EU would
have added $2,200 on average for each
motorcycle that Harley was making in the
US and exporting to some European
countries for sale so what are they
gonna do they're gonna move the
manufacturing of some of those
motorcycles elsewhere to avoid those
tariffs placed on the United States by
the European Union it actually doesn't
hurt Harley this is what so many people
don't get this is mostly just bad for
consumers Harley avoids an extra twenty
two hundred dollars in costs by moving
the jobs out of the US it's the workers
whose work won't be needed the wages
that they won't earn won't be taxed here
the small businesses that would have
made money by those workers going and
spending their wages are going to suffer
and the United States as a whole loses
exports loses jobs loses tax revenue but
Harley is going to be ok Harley will
make their bikes elsewhere they'll some
seldom
the European markets anyway and if this
continues it's only going to get worse
for American workers more than a third
of all Harley's are sold internationally
as of a couple years ago if they
continue to shift production out of the
u.s. to maintain profits on those
international sales who losses not
Harley not Trump but middle-class
workers and I was reminded of that part
of Donald Trump's tax bill were they
lowered taxes on corporations and they
said by lowering taxes on corporations
we're gonna bring money back to the
United States
we're gonna bring jobs and production of
stuff back to the United States of
course that's not how it works the
tariff policy is causing the opposite
these are supply-side handouts to the
rich and corporations and what they
encourage is profit taking and it's the
epitome of Trump fiscal policy people
get tricked by short term benefits
without realizing the long term
implications hey the tax cut was good
for me because now I get a slightly
bigger paycheck right but the long-term
effect is massive damage to the lower in
middle class in exchange for cash for
the rich that's not good over the long
term same thing with the tariffs the
short term is that Trump is the big
alpha male who's not going to get pushed
around and he's gonna tariff other
countries
well the medium in the long term is that
we are damaging relationships with our
allies and in the end we are losing
economically since they retaliate with
tariffs and we lose jobs I don't know if
you're familiar Pat with the term
Pyrrhic victory a Pyrrhic victory is one
where in winning something you suffer
such losses that it's hard to even
really call it a win overall yeah and in
a way I think that's that that's what we
have going on here I think that that is
what the Trump fiscal policy effectively
is yeah like if Arjun tena wins the big
soccer game but Leonel Messi gets
injured in the in the scheme of it all
right yeah well we don't talk about that
but that's why why would anyone even
mention Leo Messi getting injured I mean
that just seems like the last thing we
should ever talk about but I mean I
guess if you applied it to some other
team that might be an example you know
there are some Trump supporters out
there who maintain that this trade war
stuff is all
the bluff by Trump and sure tariffs are
being imposed on both sides but they'll
all fizzle out well companies have to
make long-term investment decisions and
if Harley doesn't know what the
short-term you know situation is going
to be like for their company they're
gonna go elsewhere not only that even if
they're bluffs they still damage our
relationships with allies so even if
they end up fizzling out the mere
process of trying to put the tariffs in
still damages our relationships with
allies absolute and total disaster
Harley is not going to be the last or
only company to do this